[Music]
the Broward County Sheriff's Office is
in full cya mode this evening pushing
back against an avalanche of criticism
about questions of its conduct during
the Stoneham Douglass school shooting
that includes information first reported
exclusively on the angle when a
well-placed source told us that deputies
were told not to enter the school during
the shooting unless their body cameras
were on a charge now being denied the
Sheriff's Office is also denying reports
that a captain told deputies to form a
perimeter around the scene instead of
going in to confront the shooter
it says the perimeter was formed after
the shooting had stopped joining us now
with reaction is Jeff Bell president of
the Broward County Sheriff's deputy's
Association and former LA Police
detective Mark Fuhrman gentlemen great
to see you Jeff let's start with you boy
they were issuing today after all these
days that these reports were out there a
flurry of denials let me read to you
what the Broward Sheriff's Office said
in its fact check on body cameras any
suggestion suggestion that sheriff Scott
Israel or any other deputy from Broward
Sheriff's Office ordered body cameras to
be turned on prior to entering the
school is false what's your reaction to
that we had two well-placed sources tell
us that in fact it was the case that
they were told not to enter unless they
had their body cameras on well I think
this just further affirms the union's
position that we're calling for the
Broward Sheriff's Office to be totally
transparent in this investigation and to
release the information out there
because by releasing parts of this
information that they have today it just
further creates more speculation that
there's some hidden truth back there
their mayor name may not be but it sure
does give the appearance that something
is being hidden from the public mark
there seems to have been a quite a lag
in the Sheriff's Office
you know releasing these clarifications
or fact checks there's obviously
enormous pressure on Scott Israel to
resign given the repeated visits to
the Cruz household the red flags one
after the other missed but now he says
well the this idea that there was a
perimeter set up that was only set up
after the shooting had ceased from what
you're gathering and what you've seen
what's your reaction to these series of
fact checks released today well Laura if
I was going to assume that this captain
this female captain ordered a perimeter
to be set up while she's not at the
scene that would be that would go
against every tactical operation that
I've ever heard of been part of or
anything else the the people that were
in charge of that scene were the
deputies that first arrived they were in
charge of that tactical scene they make
all the calls to have anybody make any
kind of a call on the radio is
incompetence at the very best and
probably gets worse from there there it
seems that there is nothing that they
can account for immediately it takes
them a week ten days to come up with an
excuse that still doesn't pass muster on
what happened at that location those
deputies didn't go in for a reason but
that doesn't let them off the hook those
deputies are deputies they're cops they
have a situation there and they need to
act they don't have to wait for an order
they're capable and trained they need to
go in and confront the shooter that was
their job and Jeff when you go back and
look at this horrific situation the
horrific shooting uh we all know we
support our police we love our police
officers we love our first responders
but we also can learn from what happened
on that day every wants to run to gun
control I get it that's what that's what
the left is gonna do and even some
Republicans but we do have some basic
facts that that are just facts that we
would certainly learn about if we had
the police transmission over the radio
released and this reminds me of the LA
I'm excuse me the Las Vegas shooting
where we still haven't seen videotapes
of the shooter checking into the hotel
bringing all the bags like we just like
it never happened we never see the video
why haven't we seen more video and why
haven't we heard the audio of the police
response Jeff I want I'd like your
response and then mark very quickly well
that's a million-dollar question that
nobody knows the answer to and that's
why we're demanding the transparency on
this listen if we did something wrong we
did something wrong what's learned from
this and move forward the only way to
recognize that there's a problem is to
actually be honest and truthful for it
but we have to move forward with better
training in this agency I've said it
before 887 million dollar revised budget
last year in the Sheriff's Office and we
don't even have our own gun range that's
unacceptable and the training that we do
have I got to give credit to the
sergeant's and deputies that put on the
classes with what little they have to
work with but if we're gonna get serious
about problems like this and addressing
the next problem that comes down the
road we have to look at ourselves and
learn from incidents like this and move
forward I'll mark Laura we don't need to
wait for the videos can you imagine how
many 9-1-1 calls came out from those
children inside that school there was
probably a thousand two thousand
cellphones in that school
how about releasing some of the 911
calls because that should have been
relayed to those officers that were
responding exactly what was going down
nobody thought there were shots outside
everybody knew there were shots inside
let's let's actually get real here
everybody knew what was going down they
bobbled this when they were outside of
the school and people died that's the
long and the short of it
all right guys fantastic segment